Tenemos la ecuación 20 menos 7 por "x" es igual a 6 por "x" menos 6 y tenemos que resolver para "x".
A mi me gusta resolver estas ecuaciones agrupando
los términos constantes que son el 20 y el -6
de un solo lado, en este caso los voy a poner del lado derecho, mientras que los términos
en "x", "-7x" y "6x" los voy a poner del lado izquierdo.
Así es que para quitar este 20 del lado izquierdo,
voy a restar del lado izquierdo 20, pero recuerda,
lo que hago del lado izquierdo en una ecuación,
también lo tengo que hacer del lado derecho.
Si esto es igual a esto, para que se mantenga
la igualdad, todo lo que hago del lado izquierdo,
tengo que hacerlo también del lado derecho.
Voy a restar 20 del lado izquierdo, también
voy a restar 20 del lado derecho.
Así que en el lado izquierdo de la ecuación
nos queda, 20 menos 20 es igual a 0, se cancelan,
para eso hicimos esto, no tengo que escribir eso y tan solo nos queda del lado izquierdo "-7x"...
"-7x" y eso es igual al lado derecho de la ecuación,
donde tenemos "6x" a lo cual no le estoy restando ni sumando nada y tenemos -6 menos 20,
si estamos 6 unidades abajo de 0 y tenemos que ir 20 unidades más abajo,
llegamos a -26...
-26...
Ahora lo siguiente que vamos a hacer es llevar
todas las "x" del lado izquierdo, no queremos
estas "6x" del lado derecho, así es que vamos
a restar "6x" a ambos lados, restamos "6x"
del lado derecho y restamos "6x" del lado izquierdo.
¿Qué obtenemos?
Del lado izquierdo "-7x" menos "6x", nos da
"-13x", si tenemos -7 de algo a lo cual le
restamos 6 de ese algo, nos resulta -13 de ese algo y esto es igual a "6x" y "-6x" se cancelan,
ese fue el sentido de hacer todo esto y este -26 no le estamos haciendo nada
por lo cual nos queda tan solo -26, así es que la ecuación queda ahora "-13x" es igual a -26.
Bien, recuerda que nuestra meta es despejar
"x" y aquí tenemos -13 que multiplica a "x"
y la mejor manera de despejar la "x" es, si tenemos algo que multiplica a la "x" al dividirlo
entre ese algo, despejamos la "x".
Dividimos entonces "-13x" entre -13, pero ya sabemos que todo lo que hagamos del lado izquierdo,
también tenemos que hacerlo del lado derecho,
así es que también necesitamos dividir el
lado derecho entre -13.
¿Qué nos queda del lado izquierdo?
"-13x" dividido entre -13 va a ser simplemente "x",
si tenemos algo multiplicado por "x"
y lo dividimos entre ese mismo algo, vamos
a obtener simplemente "x"...
esto se canceló y "x" va a ser igual a -26 dividido entre -13, esto es igual a 2,
menos entre menos es más y 26 dividido entre 13 es 2.
Así es que esta es la solución que obtuvimos
de la ecuación, vamos a verificarla.
Eso es realmente maravilloso del álgebra, que siempre podemos verificar nuestras soluciones.
Para esto, vamos a sustituir el valor de "x"
igual a 2 en la ecuación original.
Tenemos entonces 20 menos 7 por "x",
"x" es igual a 2...
y esto es igual...
esto es igual a 6 por "x",
hemos encontrado que "x" es igual a 2 menos 6.
Vamos a verificar que el lado izquierdo es
igual al lado derecho,
¿el lado izquierdo qué nos resulta?
20 menos 7 por 2 = 14, 20 menos 14 es igual a 6,
¿y del lado derecho qué nos queda?
6 por 2 = 12 menos 6, 12 menos 6 es igual a 6,
6 es igual a 6...
Hemos verificado que "x" igual a 2 es
la solución de la ecuación.